no it was just a big open space like i
could see you running off in the
distance whereas
we did like the silent hill map and some
other indoors maps where there were
rooms and stuff so it was like oh okay
if you did some juking you could lose
them yeah
like it didn't seem like we stood a
chance yeah
is that like is that like dlc or
something i only got the normal version
i don't know no i saw that you could buy
silent hill stuff oh maybe they gifted
it to me for the game oh yeah
are we missing someone yeah just trying
to ready
i'm trying to fix my my stream
uh it may not work it may not work it
may have why am i holding a lunchbox
okay i think it's good i hope you got
some biscuits in there for the old
killer
i want a biscuit i have biscuit i'm
gonna go grab my biscuits
get your biscuits baby yeah but he's not
talking about proper biscuits he's
talking about stupid american biscuits
i knew i knew this was gonna come up and
you're right
thank you i appreciate your support
during this difficult time
wow very strange i just i will have just
spammed my
entire youtube audience with streams
because i guess there's one that was 36
seconds and one that was 40 seconds they
just keep like attaching and deleting
yeah very weird i've done that
after souls boys once i forgot that mine
and john's twitters were connected by
restream and i went live and john's
stream also went live and people were
like
what's john streaming and i was like
uh one time at lawrence's place
somebody i guess accidentally hit stream
on and we didn't know for like a good
five minutes but thankfully the
conversation like i think what actually
got recorded was me being like yeah i
just felt like we should do something
good for charity today like it could
have been so much worse
i think i really just wanted to raise
somebody for charity
gearhead okay who's the who's who's the
killer
john i think right no it's oh you're
right it is here
let me when you guys are ready i'll uh
i'll meet you i'll mute y'all or i'll
die for myself i guess
you don't want to given yourself because
then we can't hear you
oh okay oh it doesn't auto mute when you
deafen as well
gotcha unmuted
that's unrealistic there are so many
[ __ ] perks
i know there's literally just pages
and the problem is every single one that
i have read i'm like oh that sounds
great
yeah which means they're all good which
means random ones
so what's the objective we're supposed
to repair that stuff and survive
fix the generators yeah generators and
once you have
oh biscuit biscuit
i'm eating cookies they're british
biscuits okay
you are eating proper biscuits yeah
oh my respect i'm muting you or not oh
you're eating a cookie
no he's eating a biscuit you talk about
that
well i'm trying to be appropriate i'm
going to get
some biscuits right now i don't like
chicken
are you talking about it sounds like are
you talking about my biscuit biscuits
would you like us to assign somebody to
butter your muffin two of you picked
murky
we need to escape the grasps of a
pedophile
let's see yeah you're not wrong
we want to activate enough generators
and then it will unlock like a door
that we can open and that's how we
escape jump
is it true that when i sprint you can
see me
uh no but you're more likely to like
scare the crows
which will oh john's and every time
okay i got you every time you fail one
of those
with the generator that will explode and
show where someone is
okay i got it already
is one of you breathing really heavily
into the microphone or is that the game
that's the game okay i see jacob
yep there he [ __ ] is
oh god well
well that well i heard him and didn't
you know it was too fast it's the
[Music]
problem
[Applause]
[Music]
wait did you get hung on a hook yeah
dude should i take the chance to escape
no no no no no no okay
he's still right by the way he can't get
both of us
john you are skirting him if you stay to
the left
oh my gosh oh my gosh so what if my chad
said is that weird voice in the game
um no that would be jacob fullerton
thank you john
uh oh oh he's coming back oh he sure
[ __ ] is
oh geez oh heck oh
[ __ ] snacks oh my gosh
oh god
would you throw something at me i would
i would like to get up
i would really like to get up could you
go away jacob
why are you bringing it back to the same
hook i don't know
[Music]
i love how um i saw one of you coming to
get me and the other one just sitting in
place and doing nothing and i was like
oh i wonder which one my savior is
working on what i'm looking for
is the lana dead no i'm alright
oh oh oh oh like a large spider
has killed me mayhaps
i think i'm dead
so um what's that loud noise
death is upon me uh yeah i just came to
get you
i'm right here well yeah i'm not anymore
so
that's happened
it looks terrible but it's spooky oops
off what happens then green screen will
[ __ ] up
i don't think jacob knows about the
trail that really really sprints yet
repair the thing oh you're repairing a
thing i
feel like i've overdue for a visit from
one of my
friends why is he doing palpatine down
here
he knows he's got a bad guy he knows i'm
here
run great job on that spacebar things
coley i've not done
either one
i'm following you
right metal gear solid that's in the
game right
jacob isn't the one doing the la la la
la la oh you can hide
didn't know that that's neat game really
needs a [ __ ] tutorial
oh pizza uh-oh pizza i don't
think so oh my god what floor is he on
john what floor is he on hello
he's actually i don't think he's near
you he's right on john right now
all right i'm gonna go get that
generator he's not terribly far from me
no no come get me come get me
but he's of course me i'm going to push
where are you
he's carrying me to a hook right now i'm
about right above you basically
it's not showing you now you'll see me
okay i see you let's see
i'm coming for you john is the singing
supposed to be the murderer in the game
what's this
oh my gosh coley you gotta save john
i didn't see one goddamn generate
jim he's down the stairs right behind
you down the stairs
hurry i'm gonna die no i don't think he
does either you should go possibly yeah
all right let's get out of here this way
he was downstairs don't sprint don't
sprint
come here john there's some uh they're
lockers you can hide and stuff
yeah oh [ __ ] he's right there oh my god
he is right there
oh my god this is a bold [ __ ] strat
holy holy [ __ ]
hello there
it's like you thought he had the the
like um metal gear solid ai clone of
vision like it translated literally
it does not get away though
oh whoops i didn't realize there's a
quick time check on
healing i just like stabbed myself
[ __ ] up the generator like almost
every time
there's a third floor are you how do you
how do you heal uh you hold
right click no no no no no no
oh my god
i'm not supposed to be in this room did
you get away with that
i want to heal
i mean i can't tell you where he's gone
but he
knows he's coming back he's yeah he is i
don't think jacob knows that you can
hide in these
look at him silly sod oh i found a med
kit
you wanna come right on stay away from
me if you know where i am i'm on the
bottom level
jacob's all over the place and i'm
hiding in a locker
[Music]
he's just keeps like he's still there
he's just circling around here go
upstairs jacob you [ __ ] bastard the
enemy ai in this game is really bad
where's he going he did go upstairs that
was the staircase he didn't
hear a generator how did you heal how do
you heal
ah yeah come over here come over to me i
will i will i will
why is there a crow above you
yeah but i had to leave you why could it
what is it that takes so long to heal
you have a crow above you i don't know i
think that you camping has done
something negative though a crow just
showed up which is how the killer will
find you i think you need to leave coley
i think um uh oh
yeah i think i think camping [ __ ] you
up there
oh no oh my gosh behind you
he's right behind you
oh my gosh or is it stairs to stairs and
said it's behind you
watch this
don't put me on oh [ __ ] you'll be nice
and cozy right there
all right so he's gone we haven't done
any generators this is impossible
i know this is really hard oh i saw him
is he just standing he's standing right
next to me yeah don't come near me
he's hiding to my left he's coming out
now towards me
he's still patrolling me you might as
well just stay away from me is this
generator the one that i think this is
the generator that was the one that
rahul was working we have to get
four generators yeah it's impossible
possible there's not enough of
us change the settings oh there's less
generators
i mean even one you know
no if we all get on the same one
but we just died so far
he's not around me now john oh no
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
a [ __ ] you stupid [ __ ] rabbit
oh this is a lot
i'm just i'm having to just press a the
whole time to stop
there we go now it's done i'm dead i'm
dead i'm dead i'm dead
i took too long i'm dead we stick
together
okay we can all work on the same
generators
okay okay
[Laughter]
i like rahul should be the next killer
you want me to be the next killer okay
hello
hey buddy that was [ __ ] up
yeah we were very upset with you jacob
i'm sorry
i don't know i didn't need to no you
went you went straight to the dark side
without even giving a [ __ ]
about us yeah the power went straight to
your head
really offensively i saw you hang me on
a hook and then wait by my body to see
if jon would come and get me off the
hook
i don't think i didn't see that i like
to have all our friends together
my biscuits fell on the floor
how do i how do i be the killer
on the left eye on the middle left
oh yeah yeah twice that's pretty cool
why are all of my perks very rare
i know i feel like i just have a lot of
them
sounds better than me what was that
what's this
in the hallway you're picking a pick and
a monster
bear with me one second just gets on the
ground i'm not covered in crumbs
oh no
[Music]
um
instantly heal one health state we want
boil over seems good a lot and bond this
seems good to me
i don't know don't worry if you're
wondering i ate them all off the floor
ace
okay
this is very stressful that's my take
yeah the this yeah the spooky that i
picked had like
throwing hatchets i was wondering what
that was when you were chasing me
you had you threw me in the back or
whatever i also had this like teleporty
thing and i kept
zooming past you guys and losing control
you could teleport as well [ __ ] that is
op oh my gosh
i could quickly float forward but not
turn left or right that much
as [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
two seconds two seconds his food arrived
in it
who me yeah no i ain't got no food i'm
starving
but i haven't got no food you get food
i'd cook for you
you cook for me you're gonna get it to
vancouver no i said i
would oh john is cooked for me one time
it was great
i did technically thanksgiving you
didn't really cook for me i just ate
food you prepared
yeah i made twice baked sweet potatoes
stuffed
sweet potatoes
wait where's my thing are you kidding me
two seconds two seconds two seconds one
okay you can't keep asking for two
seconds
and then having things take more than
two seconds
i just did keep asking for more two
seconds
it's fine yeah yeah your second two
seconds as you need
what why is this happen i just bought
something
and i can't it hasn't ungraded
oh you might need to like maybe leave
the lobby and come back in or really you
might need to launch your game
[ __ ] i did i picked i bought a
character to players yeah just close the
game down and start back up
oh send me an invite please
this again oh they're alphabetical that
helps
uh if you should watch if i took lobby
there you go
let's hop up i can't see you
now you're best friends installed in 10
yeah i don't know
are you playing on a different account
what oh did you close your game closure
game
yeah okay
i thought you had a ghost account and
you added me with a dummy account and
i'm just looking at the dummy account
feeling like a dummy oh
[Laughter]
um my knee is good no i've got newly
acquired has been automatically
installed
it's uh oh i'm not gonna stick it hurts
the same amount every day
no i'm actually using the company steam
account break something i guess
it's taller i'm ready to uh blight
manner i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready for
a blind manner i'm using netflix
i'm spending that netflix money a
reading gloss did i say blight manner
you didn't helping me when i look at
screens lately but i'm not precious
another
might not have spoken to you for the
rest of the uh thing for getting their
show wrong
a giant red shirt i don't want our
goddamn red shirt i don't wear a
camouflage can't help
how little we've all acknowledged my
nice sweater
why is it says why does discord ask me
if i want to stream dead by daylight
with jacob
to meet you okay so you sent me an
invite right
yeah i'm in all that to do this
so john what's in that lunch box there
yeah what do you got
well that's what i i had for fluff
for it phosphorescence
cool stickers yummy
it's stickers i got a lot of cool
stickers all right i'm ready
okay i'm here
i am also ready i'm ready i'm ready i'm
ready
uh do i need to add anything to the
yeah do your loadout and you add stuff
in your loadout yeah
there's five pages of perks [ __ ] me
i feel like we're just getting [ __ ]
destroyed is that just how this game
works john
uh i also discovered that
in alphabetical order it's gonna get
good that makes sense yeah they are i'm
getting you guys knocked out
some generators when i was the killer
again no we didn't no
we didn't get one you didn't go
make loud noises together yep we stick
together
actually no well i think someone
probably needs to be realistically
we should split up and only work on our
own generators
picking perks at random because i cannot
be bothered
okay so what do i need to do in discord
i'll just mute us if right click us and
mute us
okay uh and i'm just gonna pick
that we'll listen to your banter
people in my chat keep saying the
tutorials would definitely help don't
sass me
gives a [ __ ] i will not
don't worry i got this i got this y'all
just stick with me
done uh i think it's all ready
oh yeah why oh i thought you were muting
us i wanted to just check if you could
hear us yeah
i'm muting you now okay a mute
um thinking of donating
each of you a thousand dollars to a
charity of your choice
did you say batter yeah
i'm the batterist around baby you're the
baddest
baby you're the baddest girl you are
[ __ ] dead
oh i don't like [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
i picked a perk that will all spawn
together
so now this [ __ ] has stopped
i'm gonna bend over and and you're gonna
[ __ ] me no
um i'm gonna i want to take it all in my
face
no okay yes
can't do this right
um it said that he has stealth you guys
um gross
chest
is he who wait what's the question
together oh yeah we're all
yeah we are wait okay wait where i don't
see you guys yeah
you to the [ __ ] left of me you dingus
just
all right mate mate you just i don't see
you guys
what's wrong with you are you blind oh
there you are
yes my god bulletin
okay
my god there's a scary old man behind me
here i'm bill pills here reload
god damn every game we play my mom here
i love him let's see he's very
quiet have these big ass lights on top
of him he knows we can hear him right
let's do this yeah he's insane just
choosing to be
oh no he's right that you guys he's
right there he's right there he's right
there he's right there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what is he
oh he's ghost face apparently no rojo no
god oh stop
oh [ __ ] man i can't do it i'm [ __ ] oh
god run old man
i'm trying it's not your time yet
jacob get on the generator wait hold on
we're still being
no he's right behind me still you [ __ ]
i guess i'll be back
yeah yeah fine you beat him come on cry
i'm coming back john i think he's still
on me but he's very fast is the problem
real speedy i'm just going to drag him
really far away from you guys even if it
[ __ ] me
okay sounds good well if i just make him
chase me around here okay she's just
crazy fall down
i don't like it that prompt is
so quick
[Music]
damn it supposed to be pro gamer
that prompt is so fast that's like worth
it yeah yeah
it is bad
damn my wiggles almost
worked that was really close oh we might
have to get a time
no no we can do it
i did it i i i don't know how to help
you guys i'm [ __ ] again
just keep going let's keep going okay
you gotta run you got we gotta run
i'm committing do you think i should
escape he's far away right now
when it explodes he sees the explosion
i'll be the bait
i did it oh you did do it um should i
escape
he he's not named no no no i'm coming
for you okay
oh god i thought it was hidden the genre
by he's not hiding he's
he's just hiding right next to you isn't
he again are you sure you guys don't
want me to escape
no that you have like a four percent
chance of actually escaping
oh okay and it increases or it decreases
the amount of time until you die
thank you i really appreciate you oh
he's there again he's probably [ __ ]
[ __ ] i pressed e instead of w
it was useless the whole thing was just
let me go here
wow wow i'm gonna try to find another
generator no
okay are you up in the sky you can see
like the tower
he took a photo with my that's [ __ ] up
dude
what the hell oh no
well the jonathan the generator
um that's that done
you know so i'm dead again you guys i'm
i've passed the school bus
are you dead dead oh yeah i'm [ __ ]
dead yeah
all right well good news is jacob's
perfect actually just having a regular
day
just having a great day god i'm yeah i'm
near school if you can find the school
bus that's where i am
okay and then i'll start on the
generator when you get here
i guess you could just start doing
whoops
oh did he find you no i
i wasn't paying attention when you self
heal
you have checks
sounds like he's probably coming up on
you the pizza
what are the um the spider things on
either side do you mean
[ __ ] i got scared now i think i should
probably
webcam actually nice work nice wipe boss
great job there
there's a scary sound like top like up
here maybe he's good maybe
there you go john have you seen him
anywhere
no
i've i i goofed on the generator but he
hasn't showed up
well again i think he has he has stealth
so you have to actually look at him to
be able to see him from what it says oh
that's that's good
and i just hired him oh no
just sneaking i look back there's a
freaking screen boy with a knife
in the bush run john run
i'll keep working on the generator keep
occupied
oh god
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh come on oh
geez john i don't know why he's not
talking
wrong if he muted i know so
[Laughter]
you know generator's halfway there oh
[ __ ] there we go here he is
oh i forgot the wiggle but there's a
book right here
oh john do you want me to come get you
oh oh
let me watch him he just hid behind a
rock oh
circle around on the way to that
generator running away
oh no no he's just standing back and
he's watching he's standing
[Music]
yikes okay
i'm gonna work on the generator i got my
eyes open though
oh [ __ ] balls uh oh he's coming he's
running straight for you
okay don't run it leaves a path that's
right that's right okay i'm scooting
i'm gonna hide in the closet for a
second
oh my god i don't
know where he is
i need you apparently but oh there is
okay
yeah i think he's john i think he might
be running back to you
well i'm dead yeah he is he is running
back
him [ __ ] he knows that generator again
what was that so i guess the spider
symbol means you're the obsession i'm
not sure what that means though
there's like when you have the spiders
next to your name it means you are
obsession no i think the game has done
that
not brilliant jacob brilliant work that
i don't know why it did that
i think the game recognized it the
spider thing is chosen but i'm not
really sure
this is like absurdly difficult
but also i guess we just don't know
anything
well i think i saw him for a second
through the my chat is screaming find
the hatch whatever that means
you need to look for the hatch right now
a patch that you can hear that like i
think once
see it says ore down there for
the hatch so look for that it's like
glowing
it's a glowing black hatch in the ground
and it kind of goes
okay so i just got to find that yeah if
you just run around
if you sneak around you can oh wait wait
what
he's coming for you he's coming what the
left
go right that way
i swear i just saw something on the
ground i mean he's
[ __ ] coming though no he's not he
lost
he's accept jacob just keep going around
my chat says listen for the hatch it has
a windy sound effect near it
yeah yeah okay
i feel like we can hear it yeah i can
hear wind
oh it's gone now i think i was close no
i could still hear it
but i can also hear raw fire
oh [ __ ] hell okay he's gone
he's gone i don't know i haven't even
seen him go back where
to the right go to the right nope
go back there's a wall behind you mike
my camera's not facing the same
direction you're looking
i'm just i'm just oh [ __ ] did he see you
oh he's a big boy he's making it
difficult
my god
i believe in you i think you could be
the best killer yet
yeah i think that i'm actually gonna
give you guys a chance is what i'm gonna
do
i'm gonna try and make it a little bit
easier for you i'm just gonna you know
let you oh really on purpose well yeah
genuinely because it just seems mean
the game just seems i mean that's right
then the bloodlust sets in
yeah true um so how do i kill her
click on that little i in the middle
left and then click it again
rahul actually has to switch off first
rahul yeah oh i got manhattan
the killer back to a survivor yeah
how did this go for you lot not ideal
okay i think i liked it
yeah that's what i wanted to happen i do
like the huntress but i think i want to
go with
a new one let's do this one the hundreds
was what i was
so where do you guys you just go to see
your own loadout
situation yeah serious you have to do
the loadouts from the beginning again
yeah we can switch off and come back
what oh okay they're all telling me it
wasn't safe
are you [ __ ] kidding me oh
i liked jacob's one but i want a
different one
they seem like a couple others like i'm
into the idea of a wraith but i should
also not pay too much attention to chat
and just try to experience it myself you
know
apparently that's what i did you know
you
i mean wait what was i again you were
the huntress the huntress yeah i don't
know what a wraith is
okay
goddamn eye drops my eyes are burning oh
no
i have readied up i don't know what any
of this means
all right rahul
rahul yeah how
are you feeling you still got that
bloodlist
i've calmed down it was very fun to play
as ghostface
because um the stalking that he can do
and
i did was that did you get scared did i
sneak up on you lot a couple of times
yeah dude i was i was walking around
being like i don't see him over here
and i turned around and i just saw you
standing there in a bush with your knife
and i was like
that's pretty good just in case you were
like near me so much at the end i kept
hearing the music but i never saw you
and it was
freaking me out i couldn't yeah i
couldn't i couldn't figure way out
uh figure out where you were and the
last one
the others were the other the first i
think i kept getting alana
yeah i died both with rounds
sometimes you lot didn't even try to
save her
i don't know i never saw any of you try
and get the other one
um i was a coward telling me to do
barbecue this one
okay barbecue yeah it's barbecue and
chili it's cold
i don't there's just so many
it's been months it's been months i
haven't eaten arts
oh god i couldn't even tell you does my
own count
okay
let's see how this goes shall we i'm
ready to [ __ ] kill a [ __ ]
ready to kill a [ __ ] i think
i'll do my best everyone i'll do my best
but again
um you know having not played this game
before there's a lot going on
oh it doesn't even look that scary okay
okay how to play i guess i'll find out
oh i'm cloaked well that's fancy
i don't even
it's the fire i don't even know how to
attack
um i think i might just let them
progress a little bit though
you know i won't be mad if they would if
they succeed
okay hi hey i just want to
scare them rather than actually attack
them first is all i'm saying
you get me i just want to frighten them
a little bit hey
hey you see me bro hey
[Laughter]
hey guys hey is it helpful um
that i told you i just wanted to [ __ ]
chill out hey what
what what what what what i don't know
you could do that well now i'm pissed
off i was trying to be nice
you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
um but i did get an achievement for
playing with my food so i'm just gonna
continue to do that
um you guys uh
how you guys feeling about everything so
far oh
i'll let you you know just i'll just i'm
just gonna hang out i'll let you
accomplish some tasks it's fine
i'm just gonna
just gonna
turn around
hello [ __ ] hello hey you little
[ __ ]
you know save you a minute you try and
[ __ ] flashlight me
you little punk yeah all right that's
fine
fine you try and [ __ ] hurt me that's
what you get
you know just run along
um
yeah oh that's a bummer
you make a noise did you
it's a real shame
yeah gotta be careful with that
i'm trying to not talk too much because
i don't want to give them like
you know too much of a giveaway
huh that's interesting
it's working generator have fun with
that one
well hello there hey little [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what are you um you turning generators
on i don't remember saying you could do
that
here's the problem i don't remember
permitting any of that kind of behavior
so uh
gotta be careful with that it's not a
thing i consented to
where'd the limp come from
all right okay you know this is what was
all right really really did you think
that i was gonna be all right with any
of this
[ __ ] off ah [ __ ] ridiculous
the honestly the lenience that i give
you guys you know
i was hitting you and then i was running
away and that's how you want to play me
you want to [ __ ] with my time like that
no no we're not letting you get away
with that one i'm sorry
friends made some noise in the meantime
so
that's what you get
hey bud hi
how are you doing what are you up to
i'm just trying to hang out i'm not
going to attack you i'm just um
just trying to be your friend oh well
that was stupid
you know it was pretty [ __ ] dumb all
right well we'll leave you to it put you
maybe over
the other side or something this is a
choice you made for the record
just you'll get off it's fine just keep
tapping those buttons i'll let you off
the hook
keep going come on i'm taking i took a
long way around
about time you know i chose a really far
away hook
is that jacob let's go back
let's go back giving you a lot of
chances here you guys
okay guys i'm intentionally making it
easy chat shut the [ __ ] up
you're like why did she miss the hook
that's the whole point come on
how are you missing the point chat all
right
yeah you guys doing okay
[Music]
well you mean um excuse i literally said
it out loud
i don't mind if they win i just want to
torment them
oh that's interesting
hey how are you going
oh where are you going i don't
understand where you're going oh you
don't want to hang out
you don't want to be friends buddy is
that
the problem is here oh i thought that we
could
we could be buds maybe if you would just
come back
i'm not gonna kill you i'm being so
polite you know
i didn't i didn't have any plans to kill
you
i thought that we'd just we could just
be buddies
um i thought that you could get away
with me huh i'm getting hooked for this
one you know
this time maybe this one
see if you can make it do your best do
your [ __ ] best you're gonna get off
before i get here
you could you could
you didn't you didn't
i'm such a shame such ashamed
oh your friends did get a generator
though so that's pretty exciting
oh that's an unfortunate amount of noise
isn't it
it's a lot of progress you've just made
so you thought
so you thought [ __ ] it [ __ ]
not for long though that won't that
won't last you very long you know and
for that one
you might get in trouble i think
somebody's uh somebody's gotta take a
hit for that one
[Music]
[Applause]
jeez what am i going to do with you just
keep running away
[Music]
and you just keep making mistakes
[Music]
i really tried to let you live you know
i really
[Music]
i thought that uh we can hang out but
just didn't go down that way just didn't
go down that way
oh again huh
where are you guys going where are you
guys going why don't you want to hang
out i don't understand
where are you um where are you headed
buddy what's the plan
huh ooh oh i plugged still that's a
shame
i'm gonna smack you in the [ __ ] face
it's all right jacob is that you
jacob where did you go
huh i'm not sure where you headed to bud
i was lucky
congratulations you guys good work
you know what i'm proud of you
i'm making great progress that was a
shame though
a lot of noise
[Music]
watch out for that you know i don't
watch out for that
[Music]
buddy
[Music]
i want you guys to succeed but you just
keep [ __ ] up
oh he got away very wiggly
one left you guys think you're gonna
make it
you think it's gonna happen what do you
think
it could happen you know there's only
one left that's not very many
he's so wriggly [ __ ] sake
sorry bud i gave you a lot of chances
i gave you a lot of time just
so much [ __ ] time you know
doesn't matter didn't matter
did it
only one more you guys only one more
i think you got this
so
uh
do you go in here is that what happened
no that's interesting
we are going to damage this one though
[Music]
keep trying to keep trying
[Music]
where you going bud
just she's had so many [ __ ] chances
you know it's just absurd
[Music]
hey
you all right what's the pretty bad limp
you got there
john i don't know if you're gonna make
it
no just where are you going where are
you going
i'm right behind you just watching you
run really oh you're running around the
rock
that's cute yeah look at you go
doing your damn best doing your damn
best
unfortunately it's not good enough
sorry
oh buddy gosh
you could have got away from me there
you know really
you didn't
one sweet baby left and only one
generator left should i let you finish
it
are you gonna try and find the hatch
that's my question
i feel like i should let them win is
what i'm saying to you chad
i think i should let him win i'm
undecided but i think i kind of just
maybe i'll watch him i'll just scare him
right
hey buddy i'm right here
right behind you just bumping up on your
[ __ ] actually
so look at you trying to escape
look at you doing your [ __ ] best out
here
oh you're getting so close too
so close oh
that's unlucky what am i gonna do
should i just do that
yeah yeah crawl your way out son
go on go oh look at you go
go on buddy so much blood do you think
you're gonna make it
there you go out out you go
[Applause]
[Music]
oh hey guys
that was abusive we just beat you did
you though
did you we know
we you didn't even let us what do you
mean i didn't let you
nah we beat you shut up oh oh i got it
yeah
wow i didn't i didn't stand a chance
didn't it was worth
killing me i don't know if you were
trying to be intimidating but it just
came across
like you came across [ __ ]
i was trying to just sort of um i was
very turned on during that well thank
you i was trying to just sort of
like see as far as i could let you get
and just like if you [ __ ] up yeah i
guess i got dom
on it accidentally by telling you i was
going to punish you you did yeah that's
my best
and also because we were muted you
didn't hear
jacob because i caught i
shouted and called you a stupid [ __ ]
you [ __ ] dummy you just kept [ __ ]
up no then jacob just you know
really saved everyone really one of his
own accord
i was distracting you there was a lot of
things going on and i'd run into you to
get you away from them
i mostly found you because you made a
noise though bro this thing was like
doing that last generator and as soon as
it was done you were [ __ ] standing
behind me
i was i was behind you a lot of the time
there but it was just like
with a couple of you where i'd like
chase you around but just not do
anything
i don't know how well you guys could see
me though like i know you guys can can
we do a five minute toilet break or go
straight into another one as soon as
we've all been the killer once
break go for it quick one quick toilet
break
i'm down to keep going after 10. i feel
like normally we do two hours but i'm
done
yeah i'm up it's fun though i just
i still don't understand how you guys
are supposed to win like how do the
survivors win i don't
i i feel like if there were if there
were more of us at the end i feel like
we could have
oh you just need one more but like i was
pacing that out like
yeah you know if they were like if we
were on multiple generators and we only
needed like one more i think we maybe
could have done it and we weren't
failing checks
yeah yeah the failing the checks is how
how you're like very easily found
for sure and we also the heartbeats
would get longer and we're like
let's just stay here until she's on our
ass we're like
the moment you hear heartbeats if you go
and hide is probably better
how how well could you guys see me when
i was cloaked
when you moved pretty well oh okay i
didn't know what it looked like
all right i'll be right back oh sorry i
agree with you like that
couldn't help myself it's definitely
more humiliating to
crawl across the finish line do i watch
with you
i like i thought about if i should just
let you win and i figured i was going to
let you win but i didn't want to let you
guys win in a way that was satisfying i
wanted you to know i'd given it to you
so
you crawling bloody out the door was
quite beautiful
and i i opened the door for you as well
you could crawl across there
but i had to open the door
oh jeez amazing
i did not know that it takes a long ass
time to open the door
that last part's gotta be really hard
you probably should have gone for the
hatch i think that would have been
like probably if i know the door was
gonna take a thousand years to open
i probably would have yeah i was
[ __ ] myself doing that last
generator
yeah which i should have been i should
have already shot myself because you
were standing behind me the whole time
yeah this is funny when rahul was
running around a rock
i think it was raw hole and i was like
well now i have to kill you i was just
going to chase you
but now you have to die yeah if you
would have been able to hear us i was i
was screaming
oh were you i hope i was scaring you
because i had no idea what you guys
sounded like
apparently rahul just thought he was
[ __ ] so you know that's
my bad because i didn't do a voice
you were nonchalant that's what made it
yeah you're scaring me
good good good good perfect happy
halloween
it made it less predictable i would have
never i just thought you were behind me
whenever you're like just [ __ ] on
somebody
i was like oh god is it me there was one
part where
i think i let no there were two of you
when i put you on hooks i went for one
that was further away to let you have
the tension of spamming the
the wiggle buttons and i was like let's
just you know let's go look let's see
how far
whoa digital chainsaw says the third
hook if you get hooked three times the
third hook will kill you yeah that's why
it happened to
both uh rahul and john i think i think
that's how i killed them
it happened three times i got all this
currency i don't know what any of it
does have you all ever heard of the
movie gods oh
no i think you told me about that john
james told me about it
it's based off of a manga that's
terrible i mean i think some people like
it but it's just like
so graphic that it becomes like too much
at least for me oh my god and the anime
is that way as well but constance oh
i just replaced that with it removes all
of the like social and cultural
terribleness and it's just like gore and
it's awesome
oh cool all post link if it's
like no
it's fully animated it's 3d fully
animated it's so good
oh okay i think i've watched it three
times and i'm still
i'm like i need to re-watch this i'm
gonna google it right now give it a
google
how do i share uh i get fun fact that's
it
it's like oh my god uh i'm gonna get
myself a drink i'll be right back you
guys
okay
jacob you gotta watch gonzo
it looks cool i'm looking at right now
it's bad
[ __ ] ass guns
oh
you don't want to sleep on it like you
did dark souls
oh ooh this does look rad
i think i'm going to watch it tonight
after we're done streaming oh watch it
right now in the middle of the stream
if only it was on amazon prime then i
could do a watch party on stream with it
netflix all right who's going to be a
murderer next
i picked it all right oh i'm scared
i had like a repair i had like a the
tool box i'm not sure if it was making
the generator faster or not or what
maybe that's what it does
yeah seem pretty handy
oh oh
found something spooky i'm reading uh
i'm reading all the perks since we have
time ah yes yes yes
good things to know
alana playing with her food on that one
yeah i know that was so crazy
uh several times i would like finish in
a generator and then i'd see like a
d cloak behind me
oh heavens to betsy
oh
let's see i guess i could look at my own
perks in the meantime
yeah sorry i'm just reading
all right the flashlight seemed pretty
useful i think i was just wasting it a
lot
what'd you say jacob the fl i kept like
wasting the flashlight on accident
oh yeah me too i didn't realize
you could run out i thought there was
just a cool down yeah what's it say
there's like eight seconds
total you can use it yeah
but i wonder how are we selecting the
map
was it just random i don't see that
anywhere match
management oh maps random oh here we go
i think i can i could probably do the uh
sorry
just went for some fresh air oh it's all
good
welcome and my food was outside
so i got somewhere food
midwich elementary school
john's the monster this time are you
doing that
[ __ ] again no
yeah no jacob he's just doing
palpatine as his killing
and the jedi don't my little
friend i don't know what any of these
freaking perks are
that's a mess
very perky
hello
i have training tomorrow and i'm very
excited oh yeah what are you doing
uh i'll type it in i'll type it in
discord
oh okay i'm eagerly awaiting the answer
where do i type it
if you click on general yeah
it's just got all of our names
how do i get rid of that no sorry above
that general text chat
oh yeah yeah that one
that we are you're keanu reeves stunt
double
sorry i thought i wasn't supposed to
read that sorry
very exciting
cirque du soleil huh i also was um
the other day which is not connected to
anything but i was riding a motorbike
oh so oh yeah i love i love biking
oh do you ride uh when i
went to the desert with did you say
there are guns in this
oh for [ __ ] sake no what
[ __ ] now lana
that was amazing what she just did i
don't understand
i don't understand what just happened
i'm ready yeah better i'll tell you
later mate
okay not using a power oh no
what happened all right
here we go here we go friends i guess i
don't have a power this round
whoops oh that's not good
uh wait who is it is it john back to
dijon
can milana not be the killer i'm not the
killer
what are you are you trying to get off
rahul is that what's happening
because i didn't consent to that i'm
just saying that you're a good killer
thank you do you reckon you could do the
killer again maybe next or a couple
times more
every time why don't you i i think i
have to start charging for this
these kinds of services
all right did you guys develop any cool
strats that helped you out um
with my particular tactics i play
one-handed that's what i did last time
when you
when we were playing the last round [ __ ]
you know ooh it's silent hill
oh delightful that makes me very happy
this looks like the zombies map we
played recently is that
is he doing like clicking noises then
he's doing that rudge
grudge lady right lads
i'm going out here let's look for a
generator yeah i'm following you
what is silent hill and i will fall
for the empire oh no it's palpatine oh
the scariest of villains
rahul where are you
[Music]
i've got heartbeat yeah
what's crouch is it not see left control
now jacob's a pro gamer he's gonna never
fail us so
quick time again oh i fail every [ __ ]
one of those so
we don't have an advantage there i just
saw oh [ __ ]
every time i peek out the heartbeat goes
off i have to just
okay i'm peeking i'm peeking a lot
well that means he's between us right so
jacob we could in theory just go to the
left if rahul's got a hoppy
i have a heartbeat for a second i hope
so are you alive son
no we're good i think maybe i love
silent hill
oh god he's up there he's on the second
floor of that building you see
oh no i don't see he was kicking
something up top in the
how did you get the flashlight because
that thing stopped
i just like picked it as a tool or
whatever
what the generator here alana inside
this little hedge mates thing the
problem is i'm bad at
okay well it's happening again oh [ __ ]
he's doing a lot of yeah he's here
great
jacob run jacob i'm in a closet
class oh he got me all right i'm right
nearby i'm right nearby
i'm trying to get you actually
so what kind of monster is he do we
[Music]
he i don't know it just looks like a big
monster
he walked out into the left as far as i
can see rahu what [ __ ] are you doing why
are you at fun
i'm actually about to finish the
generator
as long as he doesn't find me that's not
cool alan is he in there
no he's not in here he went out into the
left he
went through that door i saw him go back
in i've still got mad heartbeats but i
don't know if that's just because i'm
you know i'm a generator don't [ __ ] it
up collie
oh did you do it yeah boss man okay
let's go let's go let's go
he's behind you who worried you okay
great
i see him well that happened again
i don't even know what happened oh oh i
wasn't pressing m1 when i should have
been that was my bad
okay [ __ ] bear trap what happened to
you jacob i
i got stuck in a bear trap are you out
of the bear trap
i'm out of the bear trap
i'm watching john he doesn't know how
close i am to him
where's alana i'm i'm being ahold by
john
yeah i'm watching he's calling me a
[ __ ] and then he just
excused his misogyny by saying that's
just my catchphrase
rubbish john you said it because i'm a
woman
what's happening to him okay so i got
out
i escaped oh i think wait i think it's
someone you run by
how do you feel like it's me it's me i
need healing too though which of us
needs healing more right
here okay oh my god he's coming after
you though yeah
has he seen me oh
bud i think i should heal myself
is what i'm gonna be should i heal
myself jacob
do it okay oh my god it's so slow
i'm wiggling he's gonna put me under
here he's putting me out there
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't know
that was a quick time event for
everything
he's putting down a trap right in front
of me okay
all right so just be ready to like
get rid of it or something i don't know
if you can disable the trap
so bad at healing because this this
game's
quick time [ __ ] he's coming towards you
he's coming straight towards you
okay great well all right i'm just gonna
dangle i got lots of help
he really is have i been making noise by
[ __ ] up my heels
he's right there he's right there oh
oh oh the hook it's so thick
well there he is hey buddy i'm just
trying to heal myself you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i didn't realize [ __ ] got the the you
i didn't know that i didn't know that
not that it would make it made a
difference i'm just not used to the
timing yet
nice bro oh nice coley this is
unintentionally actually working quite
well
well i was trying to stand yeah you're
probably gonna have to help one of us at
some point
oh [ __ ] oh i didn't realize how quickly
i killed all of you
oh i've already been i've already been
spited
that was fast wait a lot i'm over here
no i'm done i'm i'm i already got
spiders
i'm already done i need to learn this
game better is all i'm saying
there's a trap in front of me help
there's a trap in front of me though
there's a trap just to let
you pick up your friend i press struggle
i don't know i did press spacebar
absolutely press spacebar oh you have to
mash it oh i just hit it because it said
press
they said hit it didn't say mash wait
you already got two generic what the
[ __ ]
i mean
i'm so delicate you know oh
damn it oh it hurts we're dead
tell my story i'm going to help you out
here oh my god oh my god no no you're
fine
bail bail bail straight ahead straight
ahead straight ahead
[Music]
no he went right through the middle okay
okay
jacob just get do a degenerator as quick
as you can i'll [ __ ] with him
he's watching me i'm distracting him by
dunking just hurry up
okay i'm looking for the generators this
map is huge
i'm a freaking classroom right now
[ __ ] balls what the [ __ ] there's one
oh you already did this one
god damn it come on jacob looking for
that
oh no all right coley's been hooked
i think i did pretty well in that round
you did you were doing work
oh you did this one this one two [ __ ]
he's he's
miles away [ __ ] he trapped himself
he got trapped in his own [ __ ] trap
i keep finding your generators you've
already done no i wanna die
yeah i'm dead i'm sorry that as [ __ ]
dude it's all right john
what's jacob done now i'm gonna trapped
himself
jacob no
do you want to take your chances to
escape yeah even if they [ __ ] kill
you
i'm green oh i glitched into that one
yes roll's dead jacob
oh god oh god oh god it has been taken
by spiders i don't understand the lore
of this [ __ ] video game at all
it's a mess oh
oh yeah i forgot i'm supposed to be
talking
i thought i could go around that second
bear trap
yeah that [ __ ] you really bad jacob
that was brutal pretty funny though
i like finally freed myself from one
bear trap took
all right i'm back to the survivor okay
so i can i have i have not had a
understanding
ten o'clock it is jacobs
oh whose turn is i think so what time i
can't
[Music]
hey i watched sundered again today i've
got a problem it's good
lightning in a bottle baby we can't
create that magic again no matter how
hard we try
just like borat we do it every monday
we try to do it my phasma phobia video
going up tomorrow i think it's genuinely
pretty good
really yeah it's not sunday but it's
good
uh alana doesn't think i've been pulling
my weight in the videos guys
yeah in the first lesson you're like
half asleep you really got to up your
game
yeah was that because i was filming that
thing
yeah you had like three hours of sleep
come on why don't you make us a priority
stupid job
i really so i think that the flashlight
is the thing that i like
absolutely it's the only one that i'm
really interested in
um flashlight you use it on yeah
i never had it
oh i should plug something oh plug away
yeah what do you want to plug that's
what we do here
um i would like to plug fly mana
okay never heard of it what is it all
right
it's um it's on hulu got it
good plug scary shark
great plug i like those puns those puns
make me happy
yeah rahul wrote them himself
yeah i'm so talented i didn't do
anything on that show
i was gonna be ah the only thing i did
that was me
oh no i improvised some conversations
when i'm off camera but
um offerings what is an offering
i put a dish cloth on flora's head oh i
remember that
that was good that was good yeah i
didn't really care for that
yeah it's actually choked on my nanos
you got nando's prob yeah i just gotten
some [ __ ] food
i didn't do that oh yeah yeah
alana do you see what i'm doing
uh excuse you what's he doing
trick what did we double build
him
i have no clue he's he's just built
himself he's become bill
there are two bills those bills
[Music]
how do we stop being level one is so we
just level one forever because we're in
a private i think
we're doing yeah doing custom games or
whatever
i ordered too much halloumi oh my god i
miss halloween
what's up [ __ ] rubbery
grilling probably the best type of
cheese you can get
grilled in the cove it's um it's
actually grape
yeah there's a lot of it in australia
it's [ __ ] delicious man you have it
with breakfast mediterranean people have
it
for breakfast growing a little bit of
cheese they have it with like tomatoes
and
it's tomatoes tomatoes and potatoes
i mean and biscuits which you have you
don't know what we're saying we have to
say all the words for them
aluminum um grits whatever grits is i'm
not actually sure but they have grits i
think for breakfast
they'll get your grit what else do they
have for breakfast
oh um [ __ ] donuts for breakfast
when i first moved with my nose and i
found out that they frequently have
donuts for breakfast
i was [ __ ] concerned also they love
it
their bacon is so [ __ ] up yeah why is
their bacon so hard i don't
understand bacon is not meant to be that
crispy no it's supposed to have like you
know a little bit more fat in it
absolutely like it's like sort of
flexible i just
sounded like uh martin freeman in fargo
right there
i was trying to eat some fries and it
was [ __ ] with my
my my favorite somebody in my church
i believe that's a cool scar rubble that
they like to have
uh grits for breakfast in america
oh klieg it's clean i still don't know
what grit's actually
anywhere i still don't like i missed it
or something
all right good day jacob fullerton i
will miss you dearly
has a huge dick i didn't like that i'm
not i don't even know that
and now you've just silently sexually
harassed him there you go
all right oh jake all right jacob
the biggest dick friends why don't you
jacob does have big dick energy i'll
tell you now
jacob's dick is veiny as [ __ ] it's like
looks like it's jack
it's more veins than okay i've never
seen
all right ben okay that's fine i think
he has a
huge balance
like too big almost
[ __ ] necessary and you go i don't
know
if it's gonna be it does it always fits
it looks like a shiitake mushroom it has
like gills
why are we bullying him like this or is
this do you guys consider all these
compliments
all right lads
is it yoda stalking us yeah oh
that's good [ __ ]
so where are we i'm not seeing and [ __ ]
well uh here's the joke oh
he's going to get me he's going to get
me install brand new part was that nice
that's not how yoda lost jacob so you're
not even a fan
he's not a fan he thinks because he's
got a stupid star wars encyclopedia
oh no oh no all eight of them
oh i [ __ ] it
i just i just came over to help john
he's coming
it made it explode twice and ran away
that was the least helpful [ __ ] just
i hear him he's right next to me he's
floating around oh he's the witch i pay
so much more attention to these skill
checks than i have for
the witch it's slow the witch is okay so
here's the witch uses like blink where
she's teleported
i'm not exactly sure oh he played as the
witch the
yeah it like floats around but it's slow
so you can actually outrun it unless you
blink i gotta bounce i gotta bounce
oh um nope
i'm leaving do not please no jacob no
jacob hello
[Music]
oh he's still going for coley okay i've
got a little
something for you
um his yoda's off
yeah oh yeah
he's doing harry carey
okay jacob don't know where any of us
are
no he may not have we got any generators
yet john
i've done look i've done that when we
were on i would like
to uh but make some friends here
okay okay okay he's coming for me he's
come with me
thank you well now it's just palpatine
[ __ ] pick a star wars bro
he's got [ __ ] star wars tourette's
he's really scary looking for the record
oh [ __ ] he's on my dick my props hello
he's on my deck
oh i locked myself in a bathroom oh no
okay i just got a generator without
leave
i think i'm following jacob i i feel
like i'm stupidly
[ __ ] like okay okay
okay i don't think he came down i'm not
leaving any sprint tracks
[ __ ] off jeffy leave me alone you spooky
[ __ ]
found the generator
oh
i'm trying to keep him away from rahul
yeah he's chasing me
i'm gonna try and take him upstairs
your [ __ ] move she's she got all right
here we go
okay she's got me hooked with me
it plays a noise before i show the
prompt so if you hear the noise and you
know it's coming
you would not yeah keeps [ __ ] doing
the stupid [ __ ] palpatine oops that's
not the right thing oh
my god i heard it somebody is having a
good oops i'm gonna get it
out [ __ ] you [ __ ] hold on a minute
all right i got us moving faster i
caught it on the good [ __ ] lana
all right we've got to concentrate i
can't believe i got away with that
is he coming for us
he's coming towards us john we almost
got it we almost got it
oh yeah i forgot to use my torch i mean
he's coming he's coming now go
[Music]
you know what i'm saying so i need to
heal and i need to not [ __ ] up the heel
this time he just like ran into the door
frame as he tried to go through the door
oh god there's a crow a crow landed
right now
oh god he's right by me
hello it's like
where's the next generator we need two
more
put your cigarette out he's coming for
me you need to run away run away
because i'm making noise right now i'm
intentional
near staircases so i can fail i'm in the
middle floor there he is you [ __ ]
punch well welcome back to where we were
all right come back he's on another
generator okay i found another generator
anyway
you know the room we ran through i found
another one behind you
oh i was rohul you distracted me are you
guys on the second floor should i take
him downstairs i know you guys
oh yeah i'm on the first floor okay well
i guess i'm moving up
i can see i can see rahul i think where
are you [ __ ] come on come on
pay attention oh oh no he's coming i'm
just trying to be nice bait
you know oh she's coming no you're fine
i can hear him or maybe you're not fine
i continue to try to be the bait but
maybe i [ __ ] that one up nope he's
still coming for me you're fine you're
fine you're fine
[Laughter]
i didn't know there was a dead end there
so
should have sucked that out to me
probably you're going straight to the
bedroom
okay okay nice are you guys at least
getting work done while i'm [ __ ]
being chased by a maniac
come
[ __ ] [ __ ] cut
john john you got to get on here the
[ __ ] john
i'm still being bait for you and it's
terrible please just
you're so close to me once again why
don't we what
he's doing she's coming over oh yes get
out oh well maybe it's rahul that i'm
seeing them
oh you'll be a good boy okay okay i'm
going to get this i'm going to get this
she's downstairs i can get you yeah i
can get you i i hid in the closet right
next to you right there though
watch this there we go easy peasy
hello there oh my god oh why pick me up
immediately
jesus okay i really need a [ __ ] heel
but yeah come on
the generator right below you is like
eighty percent of the way
tight we're just taking a little trip
real
for a quick i'll be right back [ __ ] the
generator
okay i will try to get the generator oh
you want to get the generator oh
[ __ ] holy oh i can't hear the problem
because of the nominees because of the
normies
you've got a bit of time that is a don't
wanna come get me
whoa what's in me
thank you coley uh i'm going to try to
get john rahul
you should go for john's generator i
think where's john's generator it's
right
below where your generator was yeah just
drop the first floor
okay he knows where i am
i don't know how to get him he's got me
really no i've i double backed him
i don't know how to get down to you
though is the problem here there's
stairs
just there's [ __ ] staircase yeah okay
jacob because they're scared being here
well where are the things for you okay
okay
where are they oh no no you're coming
we're trying
i think
my night gown
thank you come here come here quick
quick quick quick real quick
oh i just a lot of crows no no they see
he shouldn't have done that go
uh okay i
am going to continue to try to be bait
you guys
oh yeah he's coming for us
who's he coming he's me okay okay okay i
got him oh keep
keep [ __ ] doing work all right i like
that
i'm in come in john okay we're always
got to get some generators don't worry
generator please just do the work
he's right next to me so i he's right
next to him he's on me he's he's taking
me away just go
go go go get the job done
okay that's gonna put you right up here
no but he's gonna come with me
i'm too close to your body alana you
can't see you
oh you got a mask oh that doesn't sound
good
no i don't know
i'm about to get it
having a bad time of it excuse me no
that was a dead end rojo all right
oh that was unfortunate this'll do
i'm done okay wait they're on me you
gotta get no he's killing me
i am dead i am dead
rahul you're all alone go to the exit
round
did we get all the generators yeah we
got all the generators okay
so the the bait system works super well
yeah it does oh coley oh colleen nice to
go hole nicer hole that's for holy
oh gosh you got this you got this
get the [ __ ] out of here what
don't know what that means
amazing nice
nice nice
jacob you [ __ ] suck
good [ __ ] good [ __ ] the nurse is hard to
use
yeah yeah doing blink at all yeah but if
you
if you miss like if you don't hit
somebody you're stuck there for a second
like recovering from the blink so it is
it doesn't say difficulty hard
on her
a lot of running interference while me
and jacob john were just trying to
hammer i feel like it helped a lot
because i kept like when i knew that
that jacob was going towards one of you
i would just
run nearer to you and then distract
jacob um which actually worked pretty
well
those generators were exploding like
crazy yeah oh my god me and john were
doing the most [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
we tagged and we were both missing it
so it was just floating
i was like oh my god what's happening
and because mine would explode it would
throw his timing off which threw my
timing off
that map is confusing that map is is i
think
extra tough for uh the killer because
there's so many rooms
it kind of yeah the field yeah that's
true an indoor one
here let me see if i can i'll i'll pick
another map indoor i'll try to find it
indoors
there's like people in my chat saying
that like use palette
palettes more so like i've seen that
prompt previously but i don't see it
very often
that you can tip stuff behind you when
you're running away i just feel like i
don't yeah
it just disappears really frequently i
think you just gotta know where they are
oh sorry rather it doesn't disappear you
just don't
see it that's what i'm saying yeah yeah
i guess i just didn't yeah
maybe you just get to know the maps i
don't scratch yeah
all right i've picked something that
says it's a temple so i'm
i get i'm thinking also
yeah i didn't use my [ __ ] equipped
item oh is it because i'm a [ __ ]
we gotta go to a temple now because i'm
hindu are you though
yeah suddenly is it
wait which one's the hindu one
i don't know that any of us are equipped
to answer that oh come on you lock
uh-huh yeah this is like how
um i made bruce super uncomfortable
because i wanted to name our squadron
um proud boys oh my god
something wrong with you mate can't be
like to clarify
my own discomfort
we were allowed you and me
uncomfortable as we want i don't think
people of color are suddenly allowed to
be white supremacists
i don't know that i agree with that how
i was taking the name back
okay got it okay okay okay you weren't
standing with the proud voice
you were dismantling them from the
ground up yeah
yeah how i feel about the okay hand
symbol it's like yeah [ __ ] that
that has [ __ ] been a good thing for
years
no white supremacists uh masturbate
what are we gonna do you keep saying
white supremacists
what's the white supremist what about
him sorry he knows go ahead
you man spain into me no i would never
check your privilege um my how dare you
my chat said proud boys is gay now um i
would just like to congratulate the
proud boys i'm coming out
yes it was amazing they used the hashtag
it was really good so good it was a
reference to pride boys right
like that was the point then they just
adopted it to proud boys
amazing
oh wait i haven't muted you a lot in
discord uh-oh
i'm excited [ __ ] it you don't have a few
all right because he's eating his
[ __ ] nandos maybe we'll be fine
yeah his hands are all greasy he's yeah
that freya that's on purpose
wait he was sort of like to be all
greased up shut the [ __ ] up you pricks
mute doesn't work because we just
stopped talking rahul you have to
manually do it
oh i think you could you might okay you
might have done it now you go
school-ish killer oh no he's doing
[Laughter]
oh
on my monitor so hello yeah no i'm
playing um
right next to each other [ __ ] sorry drop
my phone i'm playing uh
dead by daylight yeah you know alana
pierce
that's me yeah she's she's in our group
oh
okay i'm really bad at the quick time
events
you're just making a lot of noise
left the generator behind i'm confused
i'm stealthy boy
remember that i could be looking at yous
right now
i could be anybody got eyes on him
no but i think he's probably coming for
me oh you bastards
i feel like it's it's my time
i hear like the thing that's like hey
it's about to happen
and then i immediately press it when it
comes up instead of waiting for it
he just i very conspicuously cut into a
closet and he just walked right past me
i haven't heard him at all
[Laughter]
i lost yeah
where is i don't know i'm over by one of
the walls
near the one that you um or just at john
in a blue
come on right next to that i'll try and
continue your work
once i know he's gone
i absolutely have the worst gamer face
when i'm doing these repairs because
okay he's right next to you right here
right next to you take him i saw him
freaking sneaking around a rock
i see him right now he also he walked
past me again he's running for it might
be okay to finish this one if you guys
can
johnny yeah he's up with the template
from the temple right
i did the same thing john where i just
pressed it because i panicked so one of
them is trying to do that do you think i
don't know
that distraction to me i [ __ ] i've
started the distraction
technique your silly boss who's coming
for you so i know not to go for you
so i'll go nice
now it's reverse meta distraction no
i'm not that john i'm at the generator
you're right before okay i'm at the one
we were originally at
this oh good
uh that's why we stream so later it's
because we want to get away
we don't finish at funhouse till six so
we like to have a little bit of time
afterwards
and then we stream that's why i blew
that generator i'll go back to it a
little bit
so where do you does anyone have eyes on
him i assumed he was going to be coming
for my generator oh he's real sneaky
he doesn't seem to who's he playing
oh so we can't see him i think i just
saw him i think i just saw him creeping
okay okay he's nowhere here
i'm going back towards the uh yeah i'm
back on i asked
okay yes he is keep him running keep him
running john i'm back on the generator
all right i got mine done nice
will he get notified that it's done i'm
halfway done with mine yeah he will he
will he will oh okay
ow don't [ __ ] hit me you okay john
you on the run yeah i don't know
[Music]
i'm almost done i'm almost done my
heart's beating sean
are you okay don't worry it's fine jacob
the
do you remember the original generator
that we were on board
dead man it's right next to the global
that one has like 85
wait there's no [ __ ] hook
[Laughter]
are you just laughing on his shoulder
yeah
we're making [ __ ] quick
okay john i'm heading towards the
original one right now my heart's
my heart this isn't going very well [ __ ]
leave oh [ __ ] yeah don't heat the frame
right past you to go after me
oh okay you might be saved no he ran
right past me
okay he's always on you
it's kind of a [ __ ] you stupid [ __ ]
torch i'm blinding it got it with my
torch
i'm gonna get this one too this is so
close to being done
he's on my ass uh it takes a week to do
that
[ __ ] i think i lost him
one generator left you guys are this is
[ __ ] terrible i'm gonna get this
generated
all right i wonder where the door is oh
man oh man i'm behind you
i'm running right yeah i'm running
around you guys i'm just about to finish
this i've [ __ ] done it nice alana
it's done there it is where is the exit
yeah right there are you serious there's
two of them so we might be going for the
other one
i think he's closer to the other one
all right here we go i'll tell you if
he's near what is this speedy [ __ ]
all right john i'm in the grass right
behind you are you with that gate right
there i mean clearly
you know i'm with you making a lot of
noise yeah i feel like there's no
question about that come on take him
we're out of here oh [ __ ]
we all got away all right here we're
learning okay
nice work oh my gosh
i think he just left did he just [ __ ]
did he just hang up
were you choking on a sandwich or
something right here
no it was [ __ ] that one because um i
just didn't see anyone for
[ __ ] ages and then um
when i yeah it was just a bit of a
[ __ ] pain
and i couldn't particularly catch you
lot
i know i was eating
the eating the eating makes sense no no
no no no
you guys did well thank you i think we
were on top of our generators
um it is one more yeah we'll do one more
we can finish off on a wall
you're the last one okay yeah we have to
finish off on a longer one
we'll get
i was definitely doing something
such a [ __ ] ridiculous
deal that's a ganja club
if you've got two lines in a star wars
movie
that guy has gone down in in in the
[ __ ] legends book yeah
what guy tell that the kanji club
one-off character and force awakens i
think i want to do the one
jacob did which is um
you have to get more hatches when you
throw them though you have to find them
oh my god
after this game i have
my custom keypad keycaps all right my
mailbox i'm going to grab them and i'm
going to
replace my keycaps and rip all those
keys off all right well bye yeah
no it's after this
okay
i have you guys muted just so you know
so everybody's away i already done did
it
can't hear [ __ ]
thank you chat roger that
don't let them have it this time i don't
know probably be the same frankly
hey where are you
[Music]
guys
maybe you just shouldn't make that much
noise that quickly
that's what i'm saying
what was the plan there ronald did you
think i wouldn't notice
i think i just completely missed that
somehow is that
really what you thought would happen
somehow
you can run around in circles again bro
all right
it's okay
no worries i'll let you have it you know
run along
hmm
coley you really just went back to the
exact same spot
break that aren't we
buddy
you know i have throwing weapons correct
i just want to make sure you
are aware of that um and i'm faster than
you
you know these things or
i'm unaware of that is that a thing that
you just learned
dance all day [ __ ] day
that's the game you want to play you
know
[Music]
sorry i'll hang
just go and see how these other boys are
doing i guess
did you
where have you gone bill
that's noisy
i can hear one of you you know i can
hear you struggling
i haven't seen you though it's strange
hey bud jacob
i just want to be your friend i don't
understand
jacob what's the problem what
oh i did miss that
buddy where are you going
just trying to hang out you know
good work there hey guys
oh you got ravel down did you that was
smart
you guys have got to try to make less
noise it's a lot of noise
very very noisy okay i think this is
where i get more
it is
just kicking your generators over sorry
about it
[Music]
if you're a little foster it wouldn't be
as much of a problem
oh hello
hey bud
what's happened to you
disappointing and this one you fell
right in front of it you know just
right here oh
buddy that's the second hook too
there's some time there though
[Music]
oh having trouble over there are you
that's a shame
it's a real shame apparently you were
better at your job
see buddy
[Music]
jesus did you see someone right here i
don't know if i did you know
i'm having trouble finding you guys
doing a better job of spreading out i'll
say that
i think you're gonna get it pretty soon
you know
any minute now
oh rop rahul
it's just too dumb what
i missed
hey bud
hang you up shall we just leave you out
to dry jacob's right there too
wow that's interesting
where are you going jacob get him inside
cowardly
all right hang you up here
oh but there you go put you up right
there
make sure
[Music]
just leave you there have a good time
buddy
wow that's close by
huh
[Music]
what too high
all right
i hear you're struggling bill you should
really take that cigarette out of your
mouth
you are way too old i'm doing way too
much cardio
[ __ ] with this
i got away gone away has the fog
increased i feel like the fog's
increased
you guys only need to get one more you
know
it's not much not a lot of work
keep going at the same one you're gonna
have more problems
obviously
hey jacob
all right
i really gotta get my aim down
got some more axes stocked up you know
how it is
buddy all right let's pick you up
hurry over my shoulder i can't take you
to that one
yeah because uh
rubble already got killed on that yeah
so let's just put you
up on this one
throw you up there where you belong
what too high right
that's interesting it's a choice he made
we could play this game with john if we
wanted it's like i don't know john do
you wanna
do you wanna help jacob or do you wanna
just leave by yourself that's my
question
are you gonna leave jacob here to just
die on this hook
or are you gonna help your friend out is
that [ __ ]
you forget that i have a hatchet that i
can throw you
dopey [ __ ] oh
buddy there he goes
shame real shame you took so long i
don't know why you've done that
well i guess you left your friend to die
it's the choice that you made
jon that's what you want to do is it
and that's hey you know
it's really on you so
i'm gonna give you a chance to escape
here let's take you to this one it's
pretty far
i reckon you've got a good shot come on
you can wiggle out of it
oh so close
so close such a shame
you
that's
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
you could be pretty specific about it
but i kept forgetting to throw up like
that you could yeah oh sorry i kept
aiming wrong when i would throw up
did you find more in like the closets
yeah you just yeah pull them out
that that makes it like pretty easy
frankly
yeah they do take a little bit to um to
throw them
yeah that's it's better than the blink
of a blink i was terrible with
yeah yeah i feel good dude the
pyramid head with his like he has like a
ranged
thing that's really good oh
that was fun i'm glad i finally played
this game yeah and i feel like i learned
a lot
like we played for two and a half hours
i guess um and i feel like i
understood so much more whereas at the
start i was like what the [ __ ] is this
what am i supposed to do
but it started way more but i know how
to play the game
yeah it was a lot of fun yeah thank you
every monday
i'm down i'm sorry i'm saying okay job
that's all i'm saying
i like doing this on mondays
um all right thanks for watching
everyone i'm going to stop streaming
all right have a good one i'm going to
put on my korean keycaps
very excited for you all right later bye